BRIAN RICE: Hi, everybody.
I hope you're enjoying
Google Cloud Next so far.
In this session, we're
going to talk to you
about the value of
getting a Google Cloud
certification to help
you in your career
and to help advance the
projects that you're
involved in in the world
of cloud computing.
My name is Brian Rice, and
I work on Google's Cloud's
Learning Portfolio Team.
And I'm joined today
by my colleague, Osaze.
OSAZE IMASUEN: Hello, everyone.
My name is Osaze Imasuen.
And I'm a technical
program manager
in Google Global Networking.
Really excited to be here and
looking forward to this talk.
BRIAN RICE: Thank you so much.
Here's the way we're going to
structure our session today.
I'm going to kick it off
by talking about the roles
that are out there
in the world of cloud
computing and their demand and
how that's shaping and changing
as we move further and
further into the cloud era.
I'm going to talk about
the learning resources
that Google Cloud
makes available to help
people achieve a wide range of
Google Cloud certifications.
Then I'm going to
bring on Osaze.
And he's going to tell us
about how certifications helped
him propel his career path.
Finally, we'll wrap
it up by talking
about the benefits of
Google Cloud certifications,
both to the people
who achieve them
and to the teams that
they're a part of.
Let's start off by talking about
the demand for cloud computing
roles.
We recently did a
survey where leaders
were asked about the barriers
that they had to cloud success.
And over 80% of them identified
a skills gap on their team
as a top barrier.
And this is a really
significant problem
if you think about the fact that
more than 90% of those leaders
expect to have increased use
of cloud over the next three
years.
This tells us that skills are
a critical factor in companies'
move to the cloud.
And we know it's of growing
importance to the cloud
community, because job
postings that were specifically
calling for cloud skills
grew by more than 40%
over the two years that ended
in the first quarter of 2021.
And of course, there
was a lot of change
and a lot of upheaval
over that period.
This significant growth
tells us about the fact
that skills are fuel for
companies moving into the cloud
and revolutionizing
the way they work.
We at Google Cloud are
especially proud of the fact
that, in a survey conducted
by Global Knowledge,
the top two paying IT
certifications in the year 2021
in the US were both Google
Cloud certifications.
We take this both as testimonial
to the value of Google Cloud
itself and also to
the programs that we
offer for recognizing
people's skills
and helping people train
themselves up so that they
can achieve those credentials.
Now, cloud computing
always requires an approach
to learning and credentialing
that is focused on job roles.
After all, the roles
that people play
is how people get value
out of cloud computing.
Google Cloud technology training
is aimed at cloud solutions
rather than following
particular products boundaries.
And it's key to the solutions
that customers tried to pursue,
which was their
reason for getting
into the cloud in
the first place.
Now I'd like to talk with you
about the resources that we
make available to
help people skill up
and the certifications that
we make available to recognize
people's skill levels.
Now, when you're leading
a team of professionals,
you have to keep in
mind that people are all
starting in different places.
Everybody on a team
starts with a wide variety
of existing skill levels.
Also, people have different
preferred learning styles.
The same kind of
learning experience
doesn't work for everybody.
So that's why we offer a wide
variety of choices for people
consuming our offerings.
Some people prefer
to consume training
in a traditional
classroom-style format,
either with a live instructor
or with virtual instructor-led
training.
We have a worldwide network of
authorized training partners
that does just that.
Other learners want the
increased convenience
and flexibility of
consuming online training
with virtual lectures
and online assessments.
In order to help these
people, we make our training
available in online
channels as well,
with online training partners.
Both of those two modes
contain the same hands-on labs,
in which people can gain real
world skills using real Google
Cloud, not a simulation, that
gives them the confidence
to do new things on the job.
Finally, some learners want a
maximum amount of flexibility.
They want a la carte
learning, snackable learning.
That's why we also make
available a wide portfolio
of hands-on lab exercises that
can be consumed individually
in a safe sandbox environment.
Now, all of these
lead up to achieving
professional and
associate-level certifications.
These are benchmarks that a team
can adopt to bring everybody up
to a baseline of skill.
That's how they know they
have the right foundation
for innovating and
for scaling up.
Now, the benchmark concept
is very, very important
in the way we build
our certifications.
Their content is defined
by subject matter experts.
And they're key
to real-world job
roles and the uses to which
people put Google Cloud
technology.
That's why Google
Cloud certifications
have significant benefit
not just to individuals,
but to companies as well.
They're a well defined set
of skills that fuels growth.
There's a wide variety
of certifications,
because we know that people
start at different points
and because we know
that people have
a wide variety of interests.
The certifications range
from being targeted
at people with no
prior cloud skills
or experience all the way up
to people who have three years
or more of industry experience
and in a wide variety
of subject matter areas.
Our certifications are organized
into three main categories.
Two of these categories contain
certifications that are aimed
at hands-on technical
professionals--
the associate-level and
the professional-level
certifications.
Here's the difference.
Associate-level certifications,
such as Associate Cloud
Engineer, challenge the
candidate for the cert to map
from technical requirements
to the way a customer would
implement a solution.
The professional level
of certifications
introduces one more layer,
challenging the candidate
to map from business
requirements,
through technical requirements,
to the details of the way
the customer
implementation would work.
Finally, our credential
that is aimed
at anyone involved in
or impacted by the move
to the cloud, Cloud
Digital Leader,
contains three main bodies
of knowledge that it covers--
general cloud
knowledge, knowledge
of Google Cloud in
particular, and awareness
of the business value
and role of a variety
of important Google
Cloud Services.
Let me give you more
information about the exams
that we make available.
They're a two-hour experience.
And they're offered
in a multiple choice
and multiple select format.
The exams don't
have prerequisites
in that you are not required to
complete any specific training
or any specific
prior certifications
in order to attempt them.
We do recommend that people
have hands-on experience
for our certifications that call
for that in their descriptions.
And we also encourage people
to structure their preparation
and make sure they come
in with the knowledge
that each credential calls for.
But no prerequisites
in the realm
of training or other
certifications are enforced.
The exams are delivered
at your choice
of either a remote
location, in which case
the proctoring for the
exams is done online,
or you can go to a
physical testing center
and take an exam in an
on-site proctored system.
Finally, we make available
official study guides,
in addition to all of
the other resources
that we make available.
These books are available
from major resellers of books.
At this point, I'd
like to bring Osaze on.
Osaze, we wanted to
ask you to join us
today to tell us about
your career journey
through the lens
of certification.
Could I ask you to start off
by telling us about your career
path before the cloud?
OSAZE IMASUEN: Sure, Brian.
So my career has spanned
approximately two decades.
And I've had a variety
of roles, from hands-on
to technical leadership, to
just pure leadership roles.
And I would say
that certifications
and learning and relearning
has been a key component.
It enabled me to
progress through
from being an engineer up
into leadership positions.
Why do I say this?
Early on in my
career, I started out
trying to build
infrastructures for companies
and deliver their IT
solutions internally.
But I found that the moment
I added certifications
and that learning
experience to my journey,
it accelerated, one, my
knowledge, my learning,
and then also my scope
of responsibility.
So it's something that has
worked very well for me
in my career.
And it's something
that I continue
to use and reuse over and over.
BRIAN RICE: Super.
And tell us more about
what happened when you
started moving into the cloud.
OSAZE IMASUEN: Sure.
So before the
journey to the cloud,
my organization would
procure, build, and operate
our own internal resources.
So think of private cloud.
And at some point, we realized
that the cost and also the time
to delivery made us not meet
certain business requirements.
And we had to start looking
at the option of moving
some of those
workloads to the cloud.
Now, we didn't migrate
everything over all in one day.
We started out in a
step by step process
by doing the trial for setting
non-critical workloads first
to get a feel for how things
will operate in the cloud
and also what the security
framework would be,
because that is a
huge consideration
for anyone trying to make
that journey into the cloud.
Over time, as a
team, we got more
confident in using
resources and understanding
the products in the cloud.
We were able to move
even critical workloads
into the cloud.
And one of the
benefits, which I think
is perhaps well-known
in the industry,
is, when you run your
own resources internally,
you most often plan
for peak demand.
And that means that,
a lot of times,
you have resources
idling, not being used,
whereas in the cloud, in
the more pay-per-use model,
you're able to more effectively
use resources and also reduce
your spend if you plan
your resources properly.
BRIAN RICE: Indeed.
Well, to sum up,
can you tell us now
about how certifications played
a role in your own transition
to the cloud?
OSAZE IMASUEN: Sure.
So I've always enjoyed
learning and relearning.
So for me,
certifications help me
focus my attention
over a period of time
to learn that new
technology or learn
whatever is new in that space.
So an example with
Google Cloud is--
over a couple of years,
I was aware of using
Google Cloud platform and
also some other providers.
But when I made that
conscious effort to say,
I'm going to get certified,
it helped focus and narrow
my learning to make sure
that I mastered the content
and understood the
products and offerings
and how they related
to my business.
The end result is I've been
able to achieve certifications
in some of the
professional-level engineer
programs like the Professional
Cloud Architect, Data
Professional, and some of
the other professional-level
certifications.
Why I find these
helpful is it helps
cover a range of topics that are
relevant to the business of IT
and computing today.
And the certification
itself provides knowledge.
That is for sure.
It gives you the
confidence to be
able to interact with either
external or internal peers
or customers.
It also gives you
that confidence.
And, as well, there's
also the Google swag
in terms of the goodies,
the bags, and all
the other nice things
that Google gives you
when you're certified.
BRIAN RICE: So true.
OSAZE IMASUEN: Thank
you so much, Osaze,
for telling us your story.
Now, the last section
of our presentation
is focused on the benefits of
Google Cloud certifications,
both to individuals and to
companies and the ecosystem.
We did a survey in
the beginning of 2020
of people who had achieved
Google Cloud certifications
using an independent
third-party organization.
Of the people that
we surveyed, 78%
said that they had gotten
additional confidence
in their professional
future because they
got this certification.
82% felt like they
now had a special way
to prove their cloud
skill competency
to potential recruiters.
83% felt that their
resume or CV was now
more attractive to
prospective employers.
And finally, 85% said that they
themselves felt more confident
in their cloud skills.
IT leaders have also been
surveyed about the impact
of certification.
Out of those who authorized
training for their teams
within the last 12 months
in a different survey,
2/3 did so specifically
with the aim
of preparing their team
members for certification
or re-certification.
93% of those leaders agreed that
certified employees add value
to their organizations
well beyond the sheer cost
of the certification itself.
How much was that?
Well, 63% of them were
comfortable estimating
that the economic benefit
of those certified employees
was more than
$10,000 USD a year,
which is a significant
increment for what
is comparatively a small
investment in skills
and knowledge.
As Osaze mentioned, there's
a wide variety of benefits
for getting certification.
And some of them are swag.
Folks who achieve our
professional-level
certifications do get
excellent merchandise
that allows them to show off
their credentials in public.
Everybody gets a
digital badge that they
can put on their
profiles on social media
and display in other ways.
Professional-level
certified people
also get access to special
events at Google Cloud
Next and other venues.
They get access to the Google
Cloud certified community
so that they can exchange
ideas and knowledge
with other certified people
and seek out networking
opportunities as well.
Now, this talk
wouldn't be complete
if we didn't have
something new to present.
In order to help the
broad ecosystem get
more cloud and
Google Cloud skills,
today we are announcing
Google Cloud skills boost.
It's a brand new way to
consume Google Cloud learning.
It makes more than 700
labs, courses, and tools
for preparing for our
certifications available.
And for the next
month, we're making
it available to all of
our customers and partners
at no cost.
The URL is
g.co/cloud/freetraining.
And we hope that
everybody listening
will take advantage
of this offer
and see what we are
making available to help
people take their careers
to the next level.
At this point, I
want to thank Osaze
for joining us today and
telling us his story.
And I'd like to thank everyone
in the audience for joining us.
And we wish you all the best
with your cloud careers.